Vabbè Ragazzi allora vi spiego questa
cosa che ultimamente sul web Eh ho visto
un sacco di video dove c'è gente che
spaccia il mio numero di telefono
tralasciando il fatto che tutte le cose
che trovate su internet tipo il numero
di telefono di Favij sono minchiate
assurde perché non ce n'è uno vero ma
neanche uno potevo andare a commentare
questi ragazzi che che spacciano il mio
fake numero per farvi views Beh vi
rendete conto che se uno scrive il
mmm la prima con una delle prime cose
che esce il numero di Favij Ma state
male il numero di Favij Va bene allora
andiamo a cliccare sul numero di Favij
2.25.000 views questo ha fatto chiamata
Favij al telefono vediamo svariate e
accuratissime ricerche Con quale musica
di sottofondo me lo stai dicendo Zio
sono riuscito a trovare qualche numero
che potrebbe essere corretto per
riuscire
e Ciao a tutti ragazzi Sono mattiz e
benvenuti in un nuovo l'hai già fatto la
intro sono sicuro ovviamente risponderà
certamente
posso dire di aver parlato con lo
youtuber più famoso d'Italia dopo me
ovviamente
Questo è il primo numero perché hai
censurato il mio numero con il mio
numero con una fetta di prosciutto
gigante andiamo a chiamarlo
non è abilitato al traffico in tante
chissà perché ma quando tutto sembrava
perduto perché l'ha trovato
[Musica]
ragazzi ha squillato
potrebbe essere veramente lui
cazzo incredibile riproviamo un'altra
volta
quanto tempo
Favij
Ah ma cosa sembra un bambino di 12 anni
cosa Favij ma anche solo dalla voce come
potevi pensare che fossi io come cioè
sentite che voce ha
Favij
Ma come no i sogni di questo ragazzo
andati distrutti poverino il numero di
Favij È 366 66 sei scemo 48 Asino cotto
c'è abbondanza di comicità ultimamente
su YouTube C'è chi ha fatto anche mezzo
milione di views Come avrete già un bel
letto dal titolo oggi mi veniva dal
profondo
squilla squilla squilla
No vabbè io voglio vedere quella volta
che risponde una donna e poi il ragazzo
in questione gli risponde Favi
ho trovato il numero su Facebook questo
dovrebbe essere il numero di Favij
questa non ha capito neanche che cazzo
sta dicendo questo è il numero di Favij
no no no no no vabbè dai basta Ho
chiamato Favij in diretta 187.000
Madonna come è facile fare le views raga
[Musica]
ti sei fatto male all'altro braccio si è
sbagliato Non sto scherzando ha sbattuto
l'altro gomito quello sbattuto Ah si
tocca l'altro perché
Ahia il numero di Favij Ma se non sai
neanche scrivere il mio nickname perché
scrivi il numero di Favij con la j
maiuscola non sai neanche Qual è il mio
nickname
Ok Ciao chi sei un'amica di un tuo amico
chi ok
Sì ma non accettate con me non voglio ma
come hai fatto ad avere il mio numero ma
non chattare con me non voglio subito il
secondo dopo ma come hai fatto ad avere
il mio numero cioè sono anche incoerente
con le mie scelte non voglio chattare
con te però come stai che vi svelo il
numero di Favij ve lo prometto Ciao
ragazzi Cosa cazzo ho visto 100 like e
svela il numero di Favij
1.500 1515 like dove fottutamente è il
mio numero dove il numero di Favij ma ma
qualcuno lo sa scrivere il mio cazzo di
nome ma se fate un video sul mio numero
ma almeno scrivete Favij giusto Ma uno
scriveva Favij Oh già che mi scrivi Ciao
Ma sei fan Fammi proprio è morta lei ASP
Marco io non conosco nessuno che sia
Marco Dove l'hai preso il numero posso
farti posso chiederti una cortesia amico
mio xxx Real 27 con 101 iscritti e 37
mila vi Usa questo video se devi
impersonare me con una chat finta almeno
ti ti prego Ti scongiuro mettile h nei
verbi Ti prego non mi fai passare per
una analfabeta almeno l'h nella live
perché chi cazzo l'ha messo là la metto
laccato dov'è Dov'è dov'è la i nel nome
Dov'è la h nei verbi perché mancano le
lettere in questo video eh Sono tornato
ieri dalle 3:00 a Los Angeles ho
scoperto coperto diciamo abbastanza ha
scoperto abbastanza ha scoperto solo un
po' non del tutto un pochettino scoperto
il mio numero in alcune youtuber che ho
incontrato gabbo
però loro nel titolo non ci sono c'è
solo Favij perché Favij fa click gli
altri non lo fanno il click Se volete i
numeri di questi due questi due mi
scrivete il mio canale lasciate like e
nei commenti scrivete #scritto con di
fianco lo youtuber che volete che vi
mandi il suo numero Ma secondo te la
gente veramente ci casca in questa
minchiata incredibile Se io vado nei
commenti Secondo te qualcuno
Mamma voglio morire va bene ragazzi
Direi che per oggi basta Voglio andare a
finirmi le patatine che non è educato
mangiare durante il video Sembra un
placement sta roba però non è un
placement ve lo giuro però il tipo è un
figo però hai capito ti sia piaciuto
ragazzi per oggi concludo qui con il
numero di telefono di Favij Spero che
siate tutti contenti di aver visto che
non esiste il mio numero sul web però è
impossibile da trovare a meno che non
abbiate una terza anche abbastanza
abbondante in quel caso mandatemi un
dire e io vi rispondo con il mio nome
quindi Ragazzi vi sia piaciuto il video
come se vi è piaciuto Vi metto un Mi
piace anche per i social che condivide
noi ci vediamo al prossimo video dai
ragazzi
[Musica]